hi there internet i'm john oliver and
we're off this week but i wanted to come
back uh to talk to you anyway
specifically about the beach why
it's beach season y'all
and you know what that means don't you
it's time to slap on your sunscreen put
on your uv blocking turtleneck curl into
a ball so to expose as little surface
area as possible to the sun and take in
those rays while counting down the
minutes until you're allowed to go back
inside
there's just nothing like the beach is
there gang
but i'm afraid i have some bad news for
you because this beach season has
already developed a serious problem
specifically along a roughly 40 mile
stretch in south texas please take a
look washing up with the high tide is
something that is turning heads and
sparking reactions like this i think
it's very freaky dozens of dolls and
doll parts found stuck in the sand along
the south texas coastline if you plan to
head out to the beach watch where you
step because something might already be
watching you
burn them burn them now
i hate those dolls i hate them so much
i am here talking to you about that in a
week that we are off exclusively because
i hate them though before i do that i do
have to very quickly give props to the
local news production team there that
put that segment together because that
piano music
was both spooky and perfect and it is
the kind of attention to detail that
really sets k triple i apart from your
peers i've always said that but to get
back to my main point i [ __ ] hate
those dolls
i mean look at this one look at this
green war paint
look at these blank eyes look at the
[ __ ] skull and crossbones drawn on
its chest what does it want
what does it know
this doll alone would already be an
emergency if it were just this one doll
that had washed up i would still be
doing this video to alert people to a
gigantic problem but apparently
according to the mission aransas
national estuarine research reserve more
and more of these demon dolls are now
being found and all the time its
researchers normally survey this
particular stretch of beach looking for
creatures like sea turtles but listen to
his director explain what they've been
finding instead
sometimes it's got barnacles coming out
of the eyes or the hairs just halfway
falling off you know stuff kind of what
nightmares are made out of
i [ __ ] hate it
i hate it so much
look if you would ask me 15 seconds ago
what is the scientific opposite of a sea
turtle i'd have had a few answers for
you i might have said tortoise first you
know because it's basically a land
turtle
right kind of like left is the opposite
of right but they're both directions you
know or you know i might have said
hummingbird because it doesn't swim does
it it flies and also it's fast where
turtles for the purpose of my thought
experiment right now are slow or you
know i might have even said something
like a tree land thing not an animal
good opposite but
now i know that the precise opposite of
a sea turtle is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
which is by the way very clearly a sex
doll i get why the local news didn't
want to say it but somebody has to that
doll is different than the others in a
meaningful practical way
the point is
apparently 30 of these dolls
30
have now been found and if you like me
were wondering why
why are so many of them washing up on
the shore well that director that you
saw earlier has half of an answer for
you
it has to do with the loop current that
goes around mexico and up the east coast
of florida and we get these eddies that
come off of there and anything that's in
that current gets pushed up on the texas
coast oh right
yeah
yeah except that's not what anybody
cares about
i could not give a [ __ ] about your
unique loop currents no one cares how
the dolls got here they want to know
where the [ __ ] they came from and the
longer that no one answers that question
the more i think you're covering
something up
apparently experts say it is unknowable
that these dolls could actually be
coming from anywhere in the world and
now i am very worried that each and
every one of them is coming from a
little girl who is 4 000 years old lives
on a floating victorian house that
haunts the gulf and holds the devil in
her little heart and if you saw more of
these dolls you would believe the same
now while it brings me absolutely no
pleasure to do this i am now about to
show you more of them and at this point
i would advise you to leave
get out of here
click out of this video and look up i
don't know an architectural digest tour
of jessica alba's third most
light-filled brownstone leave me here
and never look back save yourself right
now
and for anybody who has stayed this is
now on you
because i'm about to give you a baby
parade that you are going to regret
seeing there is as we've already seen
green pirate baby which
in an extremely anonymous ominous sign
seems to be growing larger
there is also my personal enemy barnacle
baby now you might think that that's
just sand and debris on the rest of its
head but if you take a close look you'll
see it's actually even more barnacles
growing out of it you know it's like
when wasp eggs hatch inside of spiders
and eat them from the inside out except
somehow much worse
next there's barnacle baby number two
now this one
is honestly not quite so bad is it but
it seems to exist mainly to lull you
into a false sense of security so
barnacle baby number three here
can rock you to your very core and by
the way don't go clicking out of this
video now to go peek around jessica
alba's minimalist dining room you [ __ ]
up live with your bad decision and stick
it out to the end because next we have
wide flat baby which inexplicably has a
flipper then we have nightmare ghoul
baby then in a natural extension santa
you know
i don't know why anyone is surprised by
anything at this point next up there's
baby head attached to adult body then
there's baby that for reasons i don't
entirely understand is quietly the most
upsetting to me
then you've got detached baby heads just
by itself there's anthony there's that
one is just named anthony and finally
detached baby head number two look in my
defense i told you from the start i hate
these things i told you to leave and
you're still here so you don't get to be
angry with me i'm now angry with you
my staff is on vacation right now and
i'm showing you these monsters at three
o'clock in the morning i have to take
these web exclusives at 3am because
apparently during our off week 60
minutes takes over our studio to film
b-roll of their [ __ ] clock ticking
but look obviously there's a much bigger
question here isn't there which is what
are we going to do about these beasts
specifically how can we destroy them
because we have to destroy them
these beach dolls are the single worst
thing i've ever seen now do we need to
break some kind of curse that would make
sense is there a special volcano that we
have to throw them into was this a
simple matter of avenging the dead
governess of the 4 000 year old little
girl because if that's what it takes i
will do it but here's the thing i'm
afraid i have a final harrowing twist
here because it turns out these dolls
may unfortunately no longer be contained
as some are now scattered about
different owners because apparently
you can buy them
every year we host a fundraiser for the
rehab facility for sea turtles and
people actually buy these things so we
had a doll head that was a pretty good
size and somebody paid 35 bucks for it
so all of that goes towards rehabbing
sea turtles stop acting like you're
saying something fun
oh and first first would you like to
know which doll head specifically sold
for 35 big ones because it's this one of
course it is
of course it is and let me be clear that
sex doll head and the person who bought
it need to be thrown directly into the
middle of the ocean
second i simply cannot trust the
anonymous buyers of these dolls to
destroy them thirdly i quite like sea
turtles now mainly because i know that
they are the exact opposite of this i
hate this so much i hate it so much
so with all of that in mind mission
aransas reserve this is my firm offer to
you we will reluctantly buy all of the
remaining dolls that you have normal or
sex
with a 10 000 donation to the turtle and
marine wildlife rehabilitation program
that's right we'll do it we will do it
and then crucially
crucially i promise we will figure out
the best way to destroy every last one
of these pieces of [ __ ] for you for all
of you
thank you so much for watching happy
beach going everyone we'll see you july
24th goodbye
you